all right today is a day of many live
streams uh we now have another awesome
language design review part of our
incremental language development
series and I'm sort of hoping we don't
have too many
things to go over here all right select
so we've talked about these before yes
so we started talking about this idea
that
having a conditioned version of some of
the pattern-based functions would be
nice select is a conditioned form of
cases we don't have one for position and
count and where we left off was saying
okay we should inventory which functions
this would apply to and it might be nice
to have a naming convention that uses
some sort of preposition like the buy
functions so
one thing I was looking at is we don't
have any collisions if we just reused
buy but I don't know that's exactly the
direction we want to go
um
here again cases position and count are
the primary functions this would apply
to the cases we may not need because we
already have select
right to position it that would
potentially a position by or count by
and then they're just some other
alternative options
uh that I looked at that don't seem
awful
well I mean there's like position select
would be
um
so what would they be if let's say it
was select star
um we'd have select positions and select
count
and then potentially select pick but I
don't think that one is quite as
applicable and then I don't know if we
want to extend it to the predicates like
match queue or member queue what would
it mean though
you we could basically have rather than
a pattern based predicate we could have
a function
test
well I don't understand why that isn't
just the function itself I mean if it's
member Q of
I'm totally confused
why isn't it just the predicate
P or whatever yeah I mean the the
extension for memory key would be you
know
do I have any members in this function
which are integers
could conceivably be written other ways
well it's that's any true yeah I suppose
that's true
okay yeah so the predicates were one
that I wasn't sure on but I think it is
probably true that we don't need
that for member Q or match queue and
free Q is kind of
complicated right but so the only cases
we're really coming up with are position
and count right
and so this originally grew out of the
suggestion to have a select position or
select positions
that would be a condition based version
of position
no you mean a
a predicate as opposed to pattern-based
version of position yeah yeah
and and what about the possibility of a
rapper that turns how do you go from
I mean isn't it purely blank
isn't it this
isn't that always equivalent
your your example there yeah
um
sort of even here
I mean it makes me think that a more
a cleaner version of this would be
a wrapper that is equivalent to blank
question mark even Q just makes it
slightly more attractive and how would
we say it
I mean
that's what we're talking about right
yeah
um
I don't buy select positions anywhere as
a name
because
it's suggesting you're selecting the
positions you're not using select and
returning the positions
right yeah
what would be cool if we wanted to have
a wrapper name for Quest for blank
question mark F what would we call it
foreign
yeah predicate the pattern or something
with test or
is true it's probably too General
no because that's not that's yeah it's
not exactly that it's not the right
thing it's a it's a pattern object
that matches based on test which is
essentially what question mark is
okay I've got an idea what is question
mark anyway is it pattern test what is
it what does it fall for
yes yeah pattern test
okay here's a question for you all what
is the one argument for pattern test
does it have one
it doesn't yeah
so what you wanted to be what turn
blank
comma f
if patent has to one argument
matched blank question you know blank
question mark thing
then at least this would work
and I'm not sure how obscure that is but
I actually think that's a reasonably
useful thing to have something which is
just
a a pattern
that matches anything for which that
argument for which that predicate gives
true
we have the opposite direction in match
Q match Q converts patterns into
predicates
so this would be the opposite of that
yes
and it's not inverse match to you either
uh let's see
it's almost like match when
or buy actually
matched by
certainly shorter than pattern test yeah
I mean match f is perhaps slightly
relevant
[Music]
um
I don't have very many match functions
currently so autocomplete would be
pretty
straightforward you wouldn't have to tab
around much
um
I don't know
I mean that's another mechanism then for
slash semi even QX
is it useful or should we better
document blank question mark blah
I mean blank question mark blah is much
more
uh is much more flexible because you can
make the blank be some more complicated
structure and so yeah it can be
blank and all sequence Etc let's find
out where the blank question mark blah
is properly documented
I think this is not surviving this idea
yeah I mean I do like the Symmetry there
of it potentially working
in blank question mark both within the
pattern based functions and within
assignment
you know the as you said the the slash
semicolon form is very useful when
setting down values but it's not always
the most obvious
well but is this more obvious
I don't think so
I think I think it's more explicit
well let's consider it I mean okay
okay options with a conversion spec
so this was something Jose and I had
discussed a while ago
um so the specific instance that kicked
this off is that Julian date and from
Julian dates are functions that have a
Time system option
but because we don't have a dollar time
system and we run into it and is the
time system an input or output time
system
and it's potentially useful to be able
to change either one of those but we
didn't the idea of adding another Global
dollar sign
variable feels a bit old-fashioned
yeah we could say there's an implicit
time system for all inputs and you can
block dollar time system to something
else and set an output time system
that's grotesque yeah but what we were
thinking is that potentially using a
rule to say this is the input time
system this is the output time system is
both very explicit and
you know reasonably flexible to extend
to a couple of other places where I mean
we're also using that for like
translations honestly yep so that's the
example there with transliterate is
transliterate uses a rule syntax not for
option but for an argument
bit Nest correctly with the option right
it does Nest correctly yeah the
Precedence is okay so there's an example
at the bottom there too in column where
base style doesn't explicitly document
this because it
normally takes a list of rules but you
can give base Style with one base style
specification that uses the same
precedence okay so the basic point is
you're saying time system Arrow blah is
a statement of what time system it's in
time system Arrow Arrow blah is a
statement of wanting conversion is that
correct yes
but
I don't understand if the thing that
you've put in there has a Time system if
this one has a Time system doesn't it
know whether the time system the out of
time system
I mean yeah you want the case in in
Julian date is less problematic than the
one in from Julian date so Julian date
generates a number when you say time
system goes to Thai that means that
output value should be in Thai and
whatever the input is has its own time
system either explicit from date object
or implicit from whatever we specified
as the input date
what is Julian
uh date there is now
in in the example I had well that would
be a Julian date number yeah and from
Julian date that that date should be a
JD number okay well what happens if I
say Julian date and date now
you get a number oh I see it's a pure
number yeah well then you have done this
is a perfectly reasonable thing to do
um
that should also work for you know for
getting it from absolute time I assume
right there we would have their
the same type of issue and and this
could be extendable to time zones
perhaps
yeah they're particularly in functions
that are both Constructors and
containers where we sometimes do
conversion this sort of specification is
nice if you say oh I have this date list
it's in GMT but I want it to be in
uh you know Tokyo time I can sit
construct a date object and say it's in
GMT and then call time zone convert and
convert it to Tokyo time or I could say
here's the dated object
it's in GMT or it's in Chicago I want it
out and yeah I think this is perfectly
reasonable I I don't have an objection
of this okay
this last section is looking at some of
the functions that we've mined from uh
chat queries that it invented yes these
are functions it assumed existed and did
not don't actually exist
um
some of them are
slight variations on existing functions
some of them are you know we are in a
weird world where we are basically
looking to the AI anyway it's it's all
right let's take a look at what we've
got
digit sum I mean this is a pretty
trivial function in and of itself
it's just total of integer digital well
we had a thing that was called count
what is it called
I mean I think total at Star integer
digits is the right way to do this
probably
um
but isn't there a digit count
there's integer length
is that what you mean oh no the number
of of D digits in base whatever
you know what digit sum is a common
enough concept we should just have it
it's silly I mean why not just tell but
it's so it's so easy to do it's total of
integer digits which is I know but but
you see it and I'm going to argue I'm
gonna argue this is not a function to
have so I guess both so okay first of
all with Christopher
you know I think it's just kind of bloat
you know it doesn't it is so easy and
obvious and readable to write total of
integer digits and it's also just as
efficient as this the only reason to
have integer length is the fact that
that it's more efficient because it's
just doing you know floor of log base
whatever than it is to to do length of
integer digits
all right what are the use cases for
digitsum
that too we're word problems or acute
math puzzles but otherwise not a whole
lot
all right
yeah
so we'll see in a couple of cases one of
the themes with some of the functions
that aren't
aren't things I think we need to jump on
immediately is that they are different
names for existing functions so like
under that proposed but not likely
useful section there is Cartesian
product which is just outer or
potentially distribute yeah that's
that's just a question of documentation
yeah and so I think you know some of it
is documentation some of it would be you
know it'd be nice to have an easy way
where if I say digit sum either I mean I
don't think code assist is necessarily
the right way for it but if I search for
digit sum if there was some way to link
to an example that's in integer digits
yeah right right but I mean also
you know the llm is going to get more
sophisticated at looking at
documentation when things don't work
right it's going to discover digit sum
doesn't exist search widgets um you get
the total integer digits so long as we
can tell it that
um sorry I'm going back to the previous
function we have a function called uh
divisor Sigma
it does the sum of the divisors
and it uses the opportunity to raise to
a power
so I wonder whether
the the same thing can be done with the
with the digits themselves
it's a whole different operation though
one is extremely difficult the other is
triviality
well there's a different point
devise a sigma you know this math
literature going back 150 years full of
that function
yeah
that is also something people talk about
and have talked about back into the
1800s and sort of puzzle math
does it have a name
digit Sigma no
that's I guess it might be nice
with divisor Sigma I think the question
is you know how many number Theory
theorems does divisor Sigma show up in
the answer is Lots yeah so
which is both which both is because it's
a useful concept but also because it's
useful to have something called divisor
Sigma because if I'm reading through a
number three paper and I see it says oh
here you use divisor Sigma
it's nice to then just have that
function but if the number Theory papers
aren't saying digit Sigma If instead
they're saying the sum of the digits
which they're not saying nearly as much
as they say divisor Sigma by the way you
know then
I'm just learning these things right now
um
and it has additional arguments again we
could use the opportunity to do the same
thing with the digits
you know math World certainly has an
entry that says
oh well look actually mathworld claims
it has even a notation a digit sum s b
is whatever
I feel like that the standard should be
if we can find a bunch of papers that
have a standard way of referring to this
that would be an argument for having a
function for it agree but if it's just a
cute thing that people use words to
describe then it's not really well
honestly I mean we've seen enough cases
I've seen this a million times
in you know recreational math type stuff
well is that what the hell happened here
this should be reported please but the
thing is for recreational math it's no
harder to write it as total of integer
digits right if you're doing
recreational math that's a trivial and
obvious thing to do and in fact I bet
most people will do that even if we have
an integer or a digit sum function which
they won't know it exists
the argument for having it would be the
case where it would actually help you do
the math is if you're reading something
and it refers to a piece of terminology
turns out digit sum seems to be a
commonly used term
there's a lot of places which use the
term digit sum
well are we just assuming that because
the llm spit it out no I'm looking on
the web for example
well can I ask another question about
this agenda here
are these things sampled from the list
that Michael Trott sent out
yeah this is a subset of those
yeah there's also a lot of stuff on
there
about elliptic curves and calculus for
elliptic curves and and then one okay
but that's not what we're talking about
here the other one that was on Michael's
list that said it was the there was some
popularity ranking that Venn diagram was
the most popular yes but this is not
what we're talking about here we're
talking about the ones that we're
talking about here there's a separate
discussion of look I I have to tell you
I'm looking at digit sum it is all over
the web there's there's just tons and
tons of people who use that to that name
and they mean as this thing we should
have this
that Alum was useful here
it's silly not to have it it's just like
everybody calls it that people know what
it is
we should have it
and mathworld seems to even call it S
Sub B but we could just call it digit
sum
I think we need this
let's keep going for the things here
what why is Venn diagram not on this
list so we don't yeah we don't have we
didn't have availability for the
visualization team fine that's the only
reason though okay digit sum we should
have sorry guys we should have it it's
just too common
it's like okay capture graphic that's a
really weird one
I can see this being potentially useful
for generating something like form
functions you know we have sure
we I thought we had a thing like this
I mean is this
is captcha
really a thing in the modern world
it's usually not
I mean in the modern world there's lots
of different verification systems
you know like match said picture captcha
you know conceptual diagrams
notably I think a lot of those things
also they're not
you know they're also doing things like
tracking your mouse and looking at the
timing and doing stuff like that to try
and guess yeah
seems a bit old world seems like a good
thing for wfr yeah
commonest words
so we do have a list of common s words
that's available through word list and
word data we don't have a standalone
function no but what we what we do need
and what I've needed a zillion times
is somehow words ranked by frequency so
I can pick off the 10 commonest words
I think that would be easy if word
frequency data worked better
well but you don't want to be generating
forty thousand of them every single time
I mean it's also very undefined you know
what you say one of the commonest words
in an articles and articles about cats
and the answer is cat will be very
common
but
you know
right
I mean there is sort of another way you
can do it which maybe you could get
through control equals is
just a little thing with you know what
you know uh sampled entity class of
sorted empty class of
word
what the heck would that
means you you can represent this in the
whole entity class framework you use
solar energy class you can sort word
entities by frequency and then use
sample entity class to get the first n
of them okay so I think control equals
could do that that would also be fine
right but the bigger problem here is
that the problem is undefined
I mean the following thing is true
given the training set of an llm there
is an answer to what are the commonest
words
that's a ground Truth for commonest
but if instead you're just saying well I
pick cats you pick dogs we're not going
to agree on the commonest words
yeah I mean we talked about this idea of
having word frequency data have
be weighted by the Corpus we're
measuring against it for things like
being able to generate a random word
that is based at least on on usage to
some well random word based on usage
would be useful
[Music]
that would definitely be useful I would
have used that many times
yeah and I believe Francisco and his
team looked at it to one degree or
another but I think they're you know
there were some technical complications
and then there were just some
logistical complications of getting
people to spend time on it and I guess
okay but I mean you know in a sense
it's ridiculous to say you know it's
like people say I is the most common
word
but clearly not in written English
yeah it depends on the the corporate
yeah the in written English right but I
probably in spoken English I I wouldn't
be surprised if I is more common than b
I'm certainly more commonly well I don't
know the as in you in the Old English
version of you
um
uh
so I think this is a question partly for
Alan of is there a reasonable definition
because I I must say I would have found
this useful many times even to get
assorted communist words or something in
word list
yeah or the you know rank the 100 most
common accordions or word frequency data
or 1000 or whatever well right which is
the brightest stars and other such
things right
yeah having a hundred common words even
if we I mean they'll clearly be
somewhere it's pretty arbitrary at the
boundary yeah
about those things okay
now the plumbing of
uh word frequency data is an interesting
question which really needs to be raised
again
because that was messy last time I
talked looked at it yeah I will try I
will check in with Alan and Francisco
and maybe we can have collect a few
things to talk about there
what on Earth is this about I mean we
have broadcast yeah we have bracket we
have cat and bra
the this is a question if Michael says
we should have it we should have it yeah
Michael was on the fence itai was not
very enthusiastic about it
um
ask mads ask for Quantum Quantum
framework people okay I don't have an
opinion for me this is like really I
don't know
yeah
I I don't see a pressing need but I
didn't see the statistics on where this
usage was coming up so
I guess we can round up random
polynomial I don't know
what how do you define a random
polynomial
you give um
degree variable
a range
for the coefficients it should be
integer I think maybe we can allow
rational
and
um
possibly a sparsity
but I think that gets tricky oh and I
think that's harder with multivaria I
think I'm not going to find it I feel
like it would be useful if maybe people
study random polynomials and there were
known random polynomial distributions
yeah exactly and then we have a giant
system for it but I do actually use that
stuff from time to time but you know
it's a wheel I don't mind Reinventing
for myself
it is and things like this yes they're
they're all the subtleties it's just I
don't think worth
trying to make a function I think it's
hopeless random string I kind of think
it's the same thing it might write
Shakespeare
is this useful
I mean I've found myself generating
random strings but they're generally
with some specific purpose in mind
well okay the one thing I can see that
might be useful is something like random
string of
uh
you know atcg for example comma
10.
so that would be the final example there
with the the resource function
so it it takes a list yeah that's a list
but I'm saying give it a string an
initial string or an initial list for
that matter so it would be it would be
equivalent to string drawing a random
choice of characters
yup that's what I'm suggesting
I mean I have to say I have found string
tuples useful many times but that's for
rather specialized purposes
I've never heard of string two balls
it's a tutorial for
oops
it's just that
I mean it too sort of specific things
I've done
I think in general I think I think cute
little functions like this are sort of
you know
they're only really useful if they're
more findable than it is easy to write
them
but
you know if
you use them enough that you can
remember them then it makes sense
I guess
yeah I mean random string strikes me as
a prime candidate for steak and wfr
unless there's a
I kind of think that it will be I mean
it reminds me of the Rex function and
SNP it's like what the heck is this
doing like what what is this sampling
from well I know but this is kind of
distribution it will be around as you
said it's a random choice of the of the
characters of that string
so it's like some kind of uniform
distribution of strings of length and
what's random random integer is a
uniform distribution across the integers
right but I'm just in that case it's
pretty easy to imagine what that is but
in the case of strings I I just think
it's sort of
like for example the the one place I
could imagine using random string is for
testing so it's something like I just
want to generate I'm testing some
functions and I want to test it on a
thousand random strings
then maybe I would use this but then it
defeats the whole point if I have to
write three arguments about what kind of
random string I want I mean it's just
like I would just write it myself
I was kind of thinking the same thing
about random polynomials of
that when it seems useful is if you need
to test some algorithm no I know but but
then you need characteristics of a
polynomial that's the point
whereas with random string is a pretty
obvious okay so let me give you actually
no sorry strings of the same problem if
you're testing things you know that take
strings you want to test things with you
know weird Unicode characters and with
you know but the much more common case
is I want to generate a random molecule
for example or a random
you know we've wanted a random bios it's
pretty difficult what's that
it's pretty difficult to generate a
random molecule because you don't know
if the binding energies will all work
out
well it's easy enough to generate a
random biosequence
because guess what the the Brilliance of
DNA is that it always works out but why
I mean first of all why do you want a
random biopsy other than for making
demos
for making demos
that's not a great reason
well I don't know maybe there are some
we don't know what the biologists are
doing maybe they have to train some
things on random sequences yeah which
they the the the generation of the
random sequence is a microscopic part of
the whole problem
some sort of Monte Carlo method
yeah but I mean this is a look my only
argument for random string is it's very
obvious what it does
I was gonna say I had sort of the same
reservations about random date when we
first proposed it and it sat on the back
burner for a little while and then we
finally came around and said oh we
should have a random date and since
we've implemented it I use it pretty
much daily you know granted a lot of
that's testing things but it's yeah well
and similarly random point in a region
has turned out to be very useful
that one would obviously be useful
though because that's not trivial to do
yeah I know random point is great
I I think random string is not dead yet
we won't consider it Priority One but
we'll keep it yes
but we should probably wrap up from this
meeting I think let me just see
um
how do you get the month names
um so calendar data for a given calendar
will give you the names as strings date
value will also give you the month name
we don't have them as symbols
you could ask for Japanese calendar or
Jewish calendar
something more exotic
they even have months that's what they
did they have a
a counting step that is closely related
to months
19 of them
so you do Babylonian calendar
all right
it's modular differences in
transliteration potentially
and in Translation but that's probably a
thing with a lot of these
yeah that we have separate interpolation
why do these transferate into English
well so we don't
we typically include transliteration for
the date so you know if you said
calendar convert of now to Japanese you
would get a transliterated form rather
than a kanji representation can we not
say language Arrow Japanese
we can within date string you know you
could say date string of
now and
um
so what's the question here so so
the question is do we need a dedicated
function that gives you month name like
we have for day name and if so
what does
dayname gives you a symbol corresponding
to
but we don't have month symbols do we we
don't and the main reason for that is
May
we were concerned that may would be
useful for a different symbol at some
point
Yeah
March might be useful as well I suppose
so yeah
could you say that more augustly uh
maybe we'll just have all the months the
symbols except for May
um
I mean is there even value and I mean I
feel like
I mean well one having them assembles
instead of strings maybe of like
marginal value
but maybe you'd get the same value if
you really for some reason thought that
it was useful to disambiguate that this
was a month you would have a rapper
that's like month of quotes May month of
quotes April I don't know what that
would be that is I mean I think yeah
we've got date value I mean if we
if I say
date value of month I would hope I get
that
it's kind of because yeah the all of the
date element names are also keyed into
date string elements
yeah I understand
because you could ask for month name
shorts or
month Roman numeral
right
so I tend to think since there's a
couple of different ways to access this
information which doesn't need a
standalone function yeah I'm not that I
I think date value is a fine thing to
have I mean I think look mostly
arguably we need to start generating
documentation for the llm
to tell it things that you know
and then feed it as as you know
eventually as fine-tuning training to it
and then it won't be confused
I mean it's a funny Twist on the kind of
human documentation side of things
yeah I don't think we need this but we
should absolutely keep the list of how
the llm was confused because we really
should generate a a thing for the llm to
tell it how to unconfuse itself
does that make sense okay yeah I'll also
as we segment the prompting more and
more you know there may actually be
specialized prompting in these specific
areas
all right we should wrap up for now
um
great thanks see you guys later thanks
everyone
bye bye
file